[Musique]
la sécurité
de cet
un sac communique bagage
et si un nouveau départ était aussi la
quête d'un sens à une vie
professionnelle
on va vous attribuer votre compagnie et
votre section nul
à 20 ans ni ne connaît rien à l'armée
mais ce soir il y voit son avenir
dans 5 minutes tous les téléphones sont
stoppés pendant 15 jours dis-moi tu
viens d'où là de quelle région tu viens
moi je viens de Haute-Savoie c'est la
première fois que j'ai un Brest je me
suis intéressé à la marine de parler les
métiers qu'elle propose je vais loin de
ma famille mais c'est pour un petit
moment c'est le temps de la formation
donc ça va aller
ni la traversée l'Hexagone pour
rejoindre Brest et l'école de Mestras
vous pouvez encore sortir du bus c'est
parti pour 10 ans
reçu c'est parti monsieur le chauffeur
[Musique]
chaque année de nombreux jeunes qui font
le choix de s'engager intègrent les
écoles militaires il faut dire que ces
écoles ont de quoi séduire elles sont à
la fois la promesse d'une voix
professionnelle et d'un employeur
d'autant que les armées embauchent
massivement
23000 recrutements cette année un record
en ouvrant ses portes à de nouveaux
métiers le ministère des armées a fait
du recrutement une priorité en 2021 il
sera le premier recruteur de France
j'espère que vous avez fait bon voyage
maintenant vous êtes sur un site
militaire donc il va falloir se
comporter comme des militaires
des militaires et des futurs officiers
mariniers le corps des sous-officiers de
la Marine nationale
vous allez dès à présent signer un
contrat
un contrat de 10 ans qui vous lira après
signature disons dans la marine ce
contrat vous pouvez le dénoncer à tout
moment à l'école de Miss France à
l'inverse nous aussi on peut dénoncer ce
contrat
un contournable les écoles militaires
sont le premier palier du cursus de
formation des jeunes reproduits
[Musique]
pour faire ses premiers pas dans la vie
professionnelle il faut savoir partir du
bon pied
à l'école de mestrance c'est à la foulée
qu'on reconnaît une recrue
l'école de mestrance a fait le plein
mais cette rentrée à une autre saveur
la principale école de la Marine
nationale a presque doublé ses effectifs
en 5 ans aujourd'hui elle forme 1200
élèves je vous souhaite donc la
bienvenue et comme toutes les écoles
mais trans à même son directeur le
commandant était lui-même assis sur ses
banques c'était il y a 40 ans mais
peut-être que vous êtes rentré pour la
grande aventure celle qu'on vous a
promise celle que vous avez imaginé vous
allez découvrir un métier de service
et en servant la France alors vous
découvrirez l'aventure il nous revient
donc cette mission plutôt ardue et
plutôt passionnante de vous former de
vous transformer les écoles militaires
ont la cote et pour le commandant ça
n'est pas un hasard
ce qui est certain c'est que aujourd'hui
si les jeunes se tournent vers les
armées pour les intégrer c'est donc elle
les considère comme rassurante et
protectrice les susceptibles de leur
offrir justement un métier rapidement et
d'avoir une progression sociale car dans
la marine on ne peut pas rester statique
c'est évident et donc il y a un effort à
faire et cet effort là on l'appelle
plutôt l'escalier social plutôt que
l'ascenseur social puisque les armées
fonctionnent toujours au mérite
ici les élèves apprennent les
fondamentaux de la vie de militaires et
de marins
mais n'est pas marin qui veut ces jeunes
volontaires doivent d'abord valider 17
semaines de formation
[Musique]
voilà de ce qui peuvent lire dans les
livres ou voir dans les films enfin et
une fois qu'ils ont vu ce que c'était
les tensions s'apaisent donc ensuite il
y a une mécanique qui se met en place et
puis tout va très bien quoi
c'est militaire et on repart toutes de
zéro et on a la même base et on a le
même sens de réussir
[Musique]
l'armée avec ses codes et son autorité
certains veulent entrer au plus vite
dans la vie active
ni il a choisi une vie à contre-courant
il veut devenir sous-marinier
le but de mon futur métier ça serait de
conduire le réacteur nucléaire qui est
dans le sous-marin il y a des
contraintes c'est sûr mais après avec
l'esprit d'équipage etc je pense que ça
s'accepte plus facilement et ça se ça se
vit bien
[Musique]
qu'il soit au bout du monde
ou ici à l'École Nationale des
sous-officiers de l'armée de terre les
militaires se lèvent au première lueur
de l'eau
loin de l'insouciance des étudiants de
leur âge certains font le choix de
l'école de la discipline
et cette école est assez ouvert
[Musique]
c'est une drôle de vie quand on a 20 ans
c'est celle qu'on a choisi en tout cas
on a fait un choix après
alors là n'est parti de chez elle
l'essence à famille et son confort je
suis parti sur une licence de biologie
donc à Grenoble c'était pour faire quoi
tes licence en biologie c'était pour
être professeur j'aime beaucoup
enseigner et transmettre ce que
j'apprends ça il y avait quelque chose
qui manquait qui ne convenait pas
j'avais besoin de bouger un peu plus
j'avais besoin que ça ait un sens il y a
encore deux mois ces engagés volontaires
étaient de simples civils certains
d'entre eux ont attendu presque un an
avant de pouvoir intégrer l'école
c'est-à-dire c'est la transition entre
l'officier qui qui fait la conception en
vue de faire des ordres sous-officier du
récupère ses ordres les transper au
subordonné qui sont limitaires durant et
donc il fait le ciment entre les deux
parties
[Musique]
bientôt ils seront des meneurs d'hommes
et des cadres de l'armée de terre
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression que ça me correspond
mieux et surtout de pouvoir utiliser mes
talents qui étaient jusque là inactifs
on va dire je me suis un peu découverte
dans la cohésion dans le leadership par
exemple alors que j'étais pas quelqu'un
de noir
très à l'aise et maintenant ça va
beaucoup mieux
ces futurs sous-officiers commanderont
au moins une dizaine d'hommes et pour
certains jusqu'en première ligne
c'est pas évident lorsqu'on est dans une
action de feu de donner un ordre de feu
il y en a pas beaucoup parmi eux qui au
début ne savent pas hésite le but pour
nous c'est la faire gagner en confiance
d'être responsable de leur décision
bonne ou mauvaises mais prendre des
décisions c'est comment à l'école on dit
que pour entrer dans le rang il faut
savoir sortir du lot ici la formation
est sanctionnée par un examen et les
élèves seront soumis à un classement
chez les sous-officiers on a besoin de
bras solides mais aussi on a besoin
d'une tête bien faite
diriger des hommes donc il faut être
solide et être en mesure de les suivre
dans un premier temps mais si on est
incapable de les diriger il va être une
catastrophe quoi tango là c'est prépa
pour la marge de 15 km une marche
d'endurcissement c'est progressif donc
normalement sont censés en sortir plus
fort mais pas mal à l'école des jeunes
chefs
tout le monde a sa chance
[Musique]
en a même eu deux
officiers en 2017 une première fois lors
du stage commando de sa formation je me
suis blessé sur le parcours groupe donc
ça engendrait une paralysie totale du
bras gauche quand on m'a dit c'est
terminé on pourra plus retourner en
arrière là j'avais perdu toute
motivation un accident qui aurait du
compromettre son avenir reparti du
moment où j'ai commencé à retrouver le
stress que 1% de la mobilité de mon bras
j'ai retrouvé un espoir considérable et
puis c'est revenu à 100% donc quand je
suis rentré à Saint-Maixent c'était ça
ou rien je me voyais que quand
sous-officier dans l'armée de terre
c'était comme ça depuis tout petit à la
vie était là dedans
[Musique]
pour faire cette situation là
donc j'ai le cadeau dans la poche gauche
passez vous
êtes chapeau mettez votre canon
pour trouver son orientation
professionnelle il faut parfois relever
la tête
pour Marine la vie caserne a commencé un
matin d'été à Rochefort
à l'école de formation des
sous-officiers de l'armée de l'air
les aviateurs plus de la moitié des
aviateurs passe par cette école
et on a beau être un futur sous-officier
la première chose qu'on apprend à
l'école c'est à faire son lit
[Musique]
la personne de permanence qu'il a fait
ou alors notre brigadier donc la
personne qui nous encades
et en gros il va venir voir si la
chambre est impeccable propre il y a
rien qui dépasse
[Musique]
c'est pour toi indispensable d'apprendre
à savoir être avant d'apprendre un
savoir-faire oui c'est important on a
déjà des valeurs en grandissant avec
notre famille qui qui nous éduque mais
après aussi il y a des valeurs qu'on est
obligé d'apprendre par nous-mêmes et je
pense c'est important de venir ici pour
pouvoir les apprendre les acquérir puis
on apprend plein de choses aussi c'est
intéressant
[Musique]
chambre 211 effectif théorique 5
effectivement 5 effectif absent 0 en
faisant de sergent
depuis quelques années le recrutement
est confronté à une concurrence
permanente sur le marché de l'emploi
pour les armée il faut attirer une jeune
génération vers un métier hors normes et
exigeant alors pour conserver leur
recrue les écoles militaires c'est un
peu une discipline de fer dans un camp
de velours
du sol impeccable plus qu'un pet de la
Bible il m'a dit et il m'a dit c'est pas
drôle je m'ennuie avec vous
[Rires]
dans ces murs la formation militaire a
nettement augmenté sa capacité d'accueil
1500 élèves en 2020 plus de 50% en 4 ans
pour nous la base donc c'est le
combattant avant tout et la spécialité
en Suisse donc c'est un continuum de
formation une formation militaire et
ensuite la formation de spécialités déjà
aujourd'hui travaillent tous sur des
tablettes sur des ordinateurs c'est une
génération console il leur faut de
l'image donc en fait on dispense de
nombreux cours à partir de tablettes sur
nos tableaux interactifs donc tel que le
montage de démontage d'une arme la
topographie également le combat la
triangulation donc on a de nombreux
modules établis à partir de cours
digitalisés toutes les armes qui sont en
picatinées les élèves ont 4 mois pour
apprendre les rudiments du métier des
armes
à l'intérieur tu fais un bac Estelle
je suis partie en licence de
manipulateur radio en électro radiologie
médicale passer des radios faire des
scanners IRM donc j'ai fait deux ans de
première année en fait marine a voulu
tourner la page
forcément que j'avais pas forcément
envie de vivre et un métier que j'avais
envie de faire toute ma vie et de me
consacrer alors que le métier de
militaire c'est quelque chose que je
pense me correspond et que j'ai vraiment
envie de réaliser et de faire
je sais que c'est un milieu qui va
pouvoir me permettre de m'épanouir et
d'apprendre à me connaître aussi
[Musique]
le jour là marine veut nous montrer le
fruit de ses efforts comme une première
reconnaissance c'est bon
on voit que tu as les yeux qui pétaient
pourquoi c'est un moment important pour
toi c'est nos habits de cérémonie donc
dans d'ici quelques jours on aura une
cérémonie assez importante c'est la
cérémonie de notre fin de formation
alors oui c'est important c'est une
tenue importante qui c'est quelque chose
qui concrétise
pour remplir ses objectifs la plus
importante école de l'armée de terre
doit former 5000 hommes chaque année nos
élèves sont caractérisés par une très
grande diversité avec un bagage scolaire
qui commence au niveau du baccalauréat
mais beaucoup d'entre eux ont des
diplômes des diplômes académiques comme
des licences ça n'a rien d'exceptionnel
quand on questionne les jeunes sur leur
motivation
elles sont très plurielles on a des
jeunes qui vont s'engager chez nous par
goût de l'aventure on a également des
des jeunes qui cherchent à sortir de
leurs conditions et qui voit en l'armée
de terre en général et dans l'école
nationale des sous-officiers en
particulier une issue attractive
la formation initiale dure 8 mois et
aujourd'hui l'école a pris le virage du
numérique
ne vous y trompez pas derrière ces
ordinateurs ces élèves apprennent l'art
de la guerre
un simulateur en fait tous les ou les
élèves mettent en application les cours
qu'on a eu en théorie sur les
ordinateurs sous ces simulateurs avant
de l'appliquer en réel sur le sur le
terrain tout simplement pourquoi à quoi
ça sert alors de meilleure automatismes
sur les cadres d'ordre sur les comptes
rendus sur les phases de déplacement et
un apprentissage plus rapide et plus
fluide encore une fois plus
finement l'école entamé une mutation qui
va impacter l'ensemble de la formation
de l'armée de terre
les cadres du bataillon ont travaillé
pour essayer d'imaginer des nouvelles
façons de d'enseigner de mémoriser sur
du long terme et propose des nouveaux
outils qui sont des outils accessibles
via les tablettes qu'on distribue à nos
élèves et qui permettent par quiz de
répéter les connaissances vues combien
généraliser cette expérimentation en
cours ça crée une sorte d'émulation
d'enjeux un peu ludique entre les élèves
et puis lors des séances de révision
programmées les élèves peuvent à loisir
réactiver leurs connaissances avec cet
outil caout
plus de 50 ans après sa création l'école
des sous-officiers de l'armée de terre
est toujours une référence dans des
domaines de formation comme l'éthique et
l'exercice de l'autorité
c'est le képi de l'école
officiers donc que j'aurai à l'issue
d'une marche d'ici les semaines à venir
et qu'est-ce que tu prépares alors pour
ce soir donc ce soir j'ai simplement
maintenu donc la tenue la tenue qu'on
met tous les jours donc sur le quai il
va falloir faire attention parce que ce
soir c'est une cérémonie un peu
particulière donc avec tout simplement
donc l'écusson du bataillon donc tu
prends mes bataillon le chevron décolle
des
jeunes sous-officiers en école justement
ça c'est un galon temporaire en fait
c'est un galon temporaire donc on a
pendant les qu'on a pendant les 8 mois
et qui sera remplacé ensuite par le
galon de sergent tu pourras le garder je
le garderai
la nuit à l'école les traditions
reprennent leurs droits
les traits tirés les élèves se préparent
à veiller
ce qui va se passer
une heure sinon et nous remémorer les
combats de nos anciens combattants des
valeurs de la poitrine pourquoi on s'est
engagé ça va être un moment sous la même
les instants qui te touchent
personnellement oui c'est sûr mais il va
falloir contenir à l'émotion et rester
stoïque devant le drapeau
[Musique]
dans le silence de la nuit Orlane et
Foulque pourront réfléchir à leur
engagement
[Musique]
pour conquérir le cœur des futurs
volontaires les recruteurs ont un
argument imparable
les armées ne recrutent pas elle recrute
ils vont donc avoir leur premier contact
avec l'armée de l'air avec une base
aérienne et c'est ici par conséquent
nous allons leur transmettre notre
savoir-être nos savoir-faire nos valeurs
tout le sens de la fraternité fraternité
d'armes j'y tiens beaucoup la cohésion
on a besoin de 35 métiers pour faire
voler nos aéronefs les mettre en service
nos équipements et ici on forme à une
dizaine de ces métiers
nos sous-officiers dans les spécialités
techniques de la maintenance
aéronautique des systèmes d'information
et de communication ou encore de
logistique
aujourd'hui les jeunes engagés ne se
tournent plus vers l'uniforme pour
trouver seulement un emploi mais aussi
pour y apprendre leur futur métier
[Musique]
étudier sous l'uniforme une idée qui a
séduit Julien en formation pour devenir
mécanicien
même si on continue à faire nos études
on est quand même dans la vie active
et justement à la remet c'est un très
bon moyen pour ça parce que ben il y a
pas d'autres endroits où on a vraiment
un salaire complet avec une formation on
est payé pour étudier et donc ils
attendent des résultats forcément comme
n'importe quel travail c'est plus
rassurant pour l'avenir parce que
effectivement on va faire une formation
et on s'est déjà ou que on va avoir du
travail derrière ça c'est un travail
assuré et l'école de Rochefort veut même
aller plus loin depuis deux ans certains
élèvent volontaires peuvent obtenir un
diplôme en plus de leur formation
professionnelle
quand Julien s'est engagé l'école lui a
proposé de passer un BTS aéronautique
travaux pratiques dans le hangar atelier
tu montes tu montes en cabine sur le
siège
donc là dans un premier temps on va
toucher tout ce qui est commandes de
profondeur ok 5 aussi aller-retour et tu
regardes bien en cabine d'accord
bon pour moi une fois que c'est coupé tu
descends tu viendras lire les côtes de
panne d'accord
tu vois c'est le A3
[Musique]
c'est l'aboutissement
d'une partie théorique qui est assez
conséquente pour les lèvres en fait donc
là c'est vraiment très très parlant pour
lui il va vraiment manipuler sur
l'alliance
faire des relevés de côte de panne et
surtout utiliser les gouvernants voilà
donc nous ce qu'on attend de l'élève
c'est vraiment une certaine réflexion et
une certaine autonomie indépannage
progressif
on peut passer par un point B une
cinquantaine d'élèves suivent ce BTS et
l'école s'appuie sur un partenariat avec
l'Éducation nationale ici on reçoit une
formation
identique en tout cas sur les matières
générales ils ont leur formation
militaire qui est complétée de façon à
valider les compétences attendues dans
le civil et chapitre que j'enseigne moi
avec eux je les enseignerai de la même
façon dans n'importe quel lycée un BTS
aéronautique
occupé 150 heures d'enseignement en
mathématiques ici on le fait en un peu
plus d'un an en 90 heures donc ça
demande ça demande beaucoup du coup
d'investissement de leur part et ils le
fournissent
l'année dernière l'école a affiché un
taux de réussite de 98% pour ce BTS
je travaillais dans une usine où je
faisais de l'usinage où je faisais des
carter de turbo pour des voitures j'y ai
travaillé un bon moment et puis par la
suite j'ai décidé de changer
depuis quelques années les armées ont
étendues l'âge limite d'engagement 30
ans aujourd'hui
alors dans ces conditions certains
élèves ont l'opportunité de retrouver le
chemin d'école même après une première
expérience professionnelle
on a eu un enfant avec ma copine on l'a
élevé et ça se passait très bien
jusqu'au moment où on a décidé de se
séparer et donc là j'ai fortement
réfléchi à ce que je voulais faire à ce
que je voulais pour mon avenir et puis
l'avenir de mon enfant aussi parce que
je m'en occupe toujours on a quand même
nos weekends on a nos mercredi soir
on a nos vacances on a quand même pas
mal de vacances pendant la formation ça
me laisse beaucoup de temps pour voir
mon fils non je pense que complètement
ça me gêne pas en tout cas dans ma vie
de tous les jours
[Musique]
un jour comme un autre à l'école de
mestrans
les apprentis marins sont évalués à
chaque étape de leur formation
mais les élèves n'ont qu'une idée en
tête préparez leur futur école de
spécialité
alors les élèves n'hésitent pas à
revenir sur les bancs de l'école
Angèle est une des plus jeunes de sa
compagnie 18 ans et tout juste le bac en
poche
avec une spécialité de sciences
politiques et j'ai obtenu mon bec du
coup en juin dernier on arrive ici on a
du coup des niveaux différents avec des
bagues différents moi j'arrive avec un
bac je connais des personnes qui ont bac
+ 5 ici on a du soutien du soutien pour
nous aider du coup à avoir un niveau
tous les mêmes niveaux ce qui fait que
bah en cours académique on a tous les
mêmes chances de réussir
pour pouvoir prendre en compte et
accompagner l'ensemble de ces élèves
avec des profils assez hétérogènes on
s'appuie sur deux modes de
l'organisation pédagogique qui sont la
différenciation quand les élèves
arrivent on teste leurs connaissances
ces tests de positionnement nous
permettent de constituer ensuite des
groupes de besoins rythmés et rapides
pour des élèves qui déjà avec un bon
bagage et puis une formation en petite
effective pour des élèves qui ont un
petit peu plus de difficultés le
deuxième principe sur lequel on s'appuie
c'est l'individualisation c'est à dire
que selon la spécialité dans laquelle
ces jeunes vont se diriger on leur offre
un parcours de formation différent après
leur formation militaire initiale les
élèves se spécialisent dans un domaine
qu'ils ont choisi car les armées ont
besoin de combattants mais également de
spécialistes et parmi les débouchés on
trouve des métiers souvent proches du
monde civil
Angèle le sait elle a misé sur une
spécialité en pleine évolution
il y a beaucoup de spécialités dans
notre compagnie il y a des fusiers
marins des détecteurs anti sous-marins
des navigateurs de timoniaux et il y a
sittel aussi du coup ma spécialité celle
que j'ai choisi c'est les systèmes
d'information d'informatique qui a été
communication entre les navires donc
tout ce qui est transmission de messages
et puis tout ce qui touche à
l'informatique aux ordinateurs
la cyber est très attractive d'abord
parce qu'elle existe déjà et parce
qu'elle a un devenir très important et à
court terme les métiers du développement
et puis la gestion de données aussi on
sent que c'est quelque chose qui les
intéresse on est en train de créer donc
des brevets de maîtrise donc c'est le
niveau d'expertise le plus élevé qu'on
peut trouver dans la marine un brevet de
maîtrise data dont les métiers de la
gestion de la donnée des Big Data et
puis un brevet de maîtrise
transformation numérique conduite de
projets pour permettre notamment à nos
développeurs de développer une expertise
dans ce domaine là
comme un éternel recommencement l'école
bi au rythme des incorporations quatre
parents
s'il va au bout de sa formation Nil peut
espérer rejoindre l'équipage d'un
sous-marin
une élite et une sélection rigoureuse
[Musique]
mais à 20 ans on se dit que tout est
possible
ma tenue aujourd'hui on a reçu la tenue
de cérémonie mais en tout cas je suis
content j'ai bien fait de choisir ça
parce que je pense que c'est ce que je
vais faire et c'est top c'est l'esprit
c'est ce que je recherchais ce tip-top
[Musique]